my name is golf a bus in germany
how could you consulting training
services architecture pressebox hamburg
built technologies by microserver
century city bocklet guests short
overview builds the cover and last but
not least michael exner oldenburg
built booklet service matches new
technology for micro services project
spirit  of the challenges
get the
mail data module at the
international services station nothing arrive
model to communicate last one has come to us
data model photos come more
business objects customer communication
services
ford creates this microserver and image
come leibfried implement a data model
which scans from the system  of decision in
the coach on the services in the latest
version of the new version of commerce
software update services and the
chapel in abu dhabi have created from
which means that have some changes that
come data model at bio juices micro
services challenges we have the parade
double con  tainer sobotka services a
picture on and forces complexity the inscription
no funny the dreams that
comes into the wild one of technology
services communications of data in force
ntd event sourcing die dsd picture the
local state of the event in los
angeles data storage so josef kafka in
kafka's process outsourcing is justin
cash for the global kafka storage
sportevents there in kafka because of you
used look databases we create form die
events there in kafka so what we've come
up with their data base in kafka
separated chef this time crysis 2 offers
come here
in michael der is one microsoft services
inc
there is consumption of the events in remote
application that a lot more and maybe
you didn't even know who is processing
the events which must cost
because this event data motto shows you has
change we choose processing the events
because summer for services euro for
services with fair so dettmer problems
there are model commented by me model
is band take that you can h  ave is you
can have the parade local data models
and no global data motto for
communication and asset database a
communications platform to you will
have different data models for
communication and health coming data
model for communication events institute
of health it data mode for two micro
services  data communication ag example
the process and delivery processing unit
f ist snappy data model that has the
data delivery model ist
egyptians was operated before wall street in the
relevant independent days in the
play-off independence and
having to use for communication and body
went into the  exchange server network
communication services managed
services is the
process day in the case of the microsoft
system of riester network server
services or there is more challenging to
[music]
ground services and you can leave you
have to fail over the weekend
customer to be able to pay  for the order
and here there is that actually like
westhoff domain logix rotw  ild berlin with
bi is he built evans limit des
datings dating when usain bolt the domain logic
of the micro service currently the work of
the world is to make a duck rollers wait
for ever be costs the corbett block ab
the costs of the wait for ever get what
you really need of modified to no
message is loneliness on limited
service at animal rights activists just lock up
and nothing and block west so what can
you i'm actually it's fun office
communication award architects of the
communication precious is sense about
the ford for the henze the ford  is the
message later than some point in the
future is the limit service packs dennis
probably the best idea system detective agency
the derbies at the limit to business alliance
system sword of empires has a
bank presentation in the
party cellar to prepare to extend
synchronous calls shortcut
service companies services.com  is called
this is something that might be
easy because the last mainboard ran out perfectly for the balls
in the gold
cost microserver what will we have
some cases in class 10 klaus des
collagen supermicro server of the table
colada micro services seems to be
something that people are used to in
imperial n9 distributed systems motto
end up warcraft with backpack is the
islam cult office service des  micro
service intern call center service
manager
des returns and everyone here der talks
to three micro services
problem here it is at the services des
services is a band at the cortex a9
[music]
at the stars
you might and up move fleet services
because i probably  heard compensation
space extraction der get it service net
return of the thing about what you do
some cases happy heart is ok kersten des
communication costs because josef rizzoli
to the end satisfied back for hear that
i try to go do s and communication and
even be quite natural  for do business
events and fuel system is border
business events and that's one way of
doing it over to me the sword o  f the
young level of europe i'd choose to
understand first wave system the
test competition problem is the micro
services maybe commuting candidate is the
republic from the domain there chic is
so interviewer and interviewed cars
micro services zfs communication
services
here
i am patient because hybrid  health and it
services emea example is following the
process delivery posters invoicing
health service the text care of the
domain object customer value nav the
text care of the project on government
officials say the first and i pad da was
talking about that we have one day
bottle  dead rise presents represent
custom because we will have synchrones
because the customer communication
services or performance problems late
and solutions and services bacteria cbh
missed here in the service the text
caraworld customers the soft pack is
the balance for the ford custom cars and
probably one order at  baby food the
lotter demands anyway now hard
morning on  project professional
service der text care of customer
services 12 42 as well as
draft flecki service and i pad so brutal and
related herzing so maybe you will have
coming database instead casemod
implementing micro services and services
instead they have won database and in
the database der is all die  information
citizens private all the
information sheets customer information
will be the change and services index
performance and latency is motto
because it's just in monday to basic
channel chiefs lake course the world
services independence hamborner the
band is amd with in the database
appalled at the hre  used solution
that you should have much information
about the customer in the order process
as possible and is everything and say
what most likely that will be different
information immediately the lottery
concerning the customer or manchester
is high point to get that stuff the
customer service shipping interested parties
of the group before invoicing at i  nterested
in woman is the customer going to pay
for delay see gets further
and the ratings from product to product
for the ribéry an manchester city
customers and process services microsoft
data domain design talksport this
context effectively completely different
or sharia database of the vfb in customer
services  just a services to come up with
better
it's just implementers matthäus und
formentera forms distant problems for us
the feature the problem is not
hauberg and implements models that
make up dead weather micro services
asten different models now you have
different ways hobby split from system
intermot solution  packages here were
their superstar namespace in detail
using micro services and calls giant
microsoft fix modulation instead they
come get some distributed big bowl of
mudd of the north maintain the change up
you to use up with that structure and
views micro services microsoft exchange
witches but will  split screens of
issel lot of the public in the micro
services architecture so you can have the
services detroit independent lead the
network communications you can you can't
spell dem independent on sunday sell off
the public utility cabling jasmins for
the change to see what you get what you
are not in friends with microsoft
services has basically robbed micro
service of micro services today in
fritzens from lancelot the cabling bring
you have had better than you probably
need to do mar coordinated the provence
because for change the effect of
different models a lot of people micro
services community of them
der riesenbecker changes noticed even
harder and die kost for microsoft
project server hugh hefners network
performance problems latency problems
you will have real problems and son and
so i thought i bet you have much worse
projection design context the broken
mail services power services group
microsoft to
europe that is now ubisoft giants in
architect chamber 2